the head of the olympics broadcasting
that just came out made a very important
feminist statement said uh that
the olympics broadcasting coverage is
going to focus on women's
sport appeal not their sex appeal
so the tokyo olympics head of
broadcasting said they're they're going
to minimize the sexualization
of female athletes in light of athlete
complaints
that the the uniforms are
too sexy or something and they want to
make the women's bodies more covered up
and this this head of broadcasting yanis
xarcos says
you got to focus on sport appeal not sex
appeal you will not see in our coverage
some things that we have been seeing in
the past
with details and close-up close-ups on
parts of the body what we can do is make
sure that our coverage does not
highlight our feature in any particular
way
what people are wearing and you won't
see any of that stuff
this is very wrong this is not because
i'm saying that you know
the olympics should be a striptease or a
burlesque show but
the physical beauty of the olympians
is and has always been a central feature
of the olympics going back to ancient
greece and
actually it extends to all sorts of
sports these people
not even just the way i'm talking about
the men too these are top physical
specimens
these are people who have spent years
and years and years crafting
and their bodies into these machines
into these incredible specimens of
achievement and excellence
so that they can form perform athletic
feats
you you can't separate the physical
appeal of the olympians
from the sport them they're intertwined
the objectification this what this is
denying
is the way that we as human beings
relate to our bodies and relate to one
another
we are attracted to one another the
sexes are complementary men and women
are
different in this way and sport is about
physical excellence it's not just about
making the individual
athletes feel good or something like
that it's about
all of us marveling at their excellence
or at least that's what it's supposed to
be but you can't
acknowledge sexual difference now
hey i'm glad you like that clip i really
it
warms my heart now you get the whole
show you can get the whole show
on spotify apple podcasts google
play wherever you get your podcasts the
show is the michael knowles show the
episode is the january 6th commission
clown show
head on don't be an adam kinzinger go on
head on over there do it right now
you can also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]